In the seventh space is a detoxification course.
Hey, great.
You say that a phase six colds forward is not is intended for short
term use only what's considered long term use.
Okay, so the reason why it's stated that it's for short
term use is solely because of this in it right here.
This Cape Aloe.
Cape Aloe is a type of aloe that is really good.
Really good at drawing water into the colon and and and lucidity
to your mouth.
So we have another product.
It's a we have private labels from ortho molecular.
It's their super aloe 250.
It's our.
Phase six assist.
And that is 250 milligrams of Cape Aloe.
This two capsules has has 50 milligrams.
The other one is just straight Cape Aloe.
It doesn't have this trifolia in it.
And it is 250 milligrams Cape Aloe per capsule.
Now I have some people taking two of those a day.
And they would take a two of those a day for the last two years.
There's nothing wrong with stayed on it long term if you need to.
If you know why you have issues.
The people that are doing that have colon issues.
They're not ignoring the fact that they have colon issues.
They're dealing with that.
But when you have colon cancer or something like that and you need to keep your bottles loose.
There's nothing wrong with stayed on Cape Aloe long term.
It's just all the manufacturers had to put it in there that it's not meant for long term use.
And it's really because.
If you have that chronic constipation that you have to be taking a laxative of any type.
Long term you're not dealing with the reason why you have the chronic constipation that is.
That's not correct management.
But if you have chronic constipation because you have colon cancer or something like that.
You already know that we're trying to deal with that.
There's nothing wrong with staying on that.
This is actually much slower.
But any any company that uses Cape Aloe says it's not tended for long term use.
Certainly this product here could be used long term.
I'd like this product because it's only got 50 milligrams of the Cape Aloe.
The trifolio which is really good for healing the gut and the magnesium which draws water into the gut.
So this is a really good product for just my own constipation issues.
Even with the space six assist.
I don't recommend people take it on a daily basis.
Some people do.
Most people take it just what they feel like they're backed up.
They ate a bunch of meat or something like that that tends to back them up a little bit.
And they take that for a couple days and clean themselves out.
You could certainly take this long term.
This product one term.
There's nothing really wrong with that.